>> Nancy Groce: Thank you
so much for presenting
such a great Botkin Lecture.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: Oh,
a pleasure, I had a blast.
>> Stephen Winick: So,
we were interested in.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
It's always wonderful
to get an audience to, you
know, listen to this stuff.
>> Stephen Winick: That's right,
yeah and we had a pretty good
venue for it today I should say.
So, yeah we were interested
in some of the areas
that you touched on
especially some of the people
that you've worked with over
the years, and you used a phrase
that I felt was great which
was 'vernacular professors'.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: Oh yeah.
>> Stephen Winick: And
explain that phrase
and was it your creation?
Or did, have you
heard it from others?
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
I don't know.
It just made sense to me.
You know, people like Dewey
Balfa who, I mean, I had many,
many, many hours of you know,
ongoing conversations with him
about the way things
are and how things work
and who is who, what's what?
I mean he's the one who
came up with this concept
of having the first
festival in a place
where people couldn't dance.
And my initial reaction to that
was like, it's dance music.
What are you nuts?
And he said, no if they're
dancing they're not going
to be paying attention
in the same way.
I thought wow, wow, you know,
I mean that's worth tuition.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
Or what [inaudible] did,
what then [inaudible] did
you know, turning his chair
around to tell me those
stories when he realized
that the audience out there,
he wasn't sure they
understood his Creole.
He didn't know who they were.
He didn't know how they were
reacting to this but he knew me.
I had spent hours
with him on his porch
so he just turned
his chair around
and started telling me the
story and I thought way,
this is working way better.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: Right,
I mean where do you
get an idea like that?
Do you get an idea like that
from somebody renegotiating
the context or instinctively,
or in a folklore
class, a theory class
where you know [laughter]
they're saying,
how could we possibly, you know?
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah,
no and what's interesting
about it too is, so as
you explained the story,
he was on a stage
doing storytelling
which is not the natural context
necessarily for those kinds
of stories but you were on
the stage with him and so
to reorient to you was actually
giving that audience more,
an experience that was more
like how those stories
would normally be told.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
Right, they get to peek
into what would typically
happen on his porch.
We weren't on his porch
but he had renegotiated
that as much of that
as he could.
I saw something similar
at the Festival
of American Folklife, I want to.
I forgot what year it was
but Ray Hicks was there.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: A great
storyteller from Appalachia
and they had him on a stage.
It was a small stage
but nevertheless it was a
stage with a microphone.
And it just wasn't working.
He felt uncomfortable and the
crowd didn't know what they were
doing there and.
And so, what the next
day before his session
on the stage was scheduled to
happen he was over there leaning
against a tree telling a
bunch of people some stories
like which he really felt
more comfortable doing.
You know happily the stage
producer, the stage manager saw
that happening and he said oh,
okay, never mind this thing,
this is completely useless.
He just went over there and
put a lavalier mic on him
and a little speaker nearby
and it just enhanced
the sound a little bit.
And instead of telling the
stories for five people,
he told the story for 15 or 20.
But he felt comfortable
doing that.
So, you know, I guess
my point is
if folklorists are
paying attention,
the lessons are there.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
Well let's talk about
Dewey a little
because you know I've
interviewed a bunch
of Cajun musicians, Michael
Doucet and Steve Riley
and all those folks and
all of them say oh well,
without Dewey none of
this would have happened.
They all studied with him.
He really was a professor
in that sense.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
He really was.
>> Stephen Winick: They
all went to study with him.
So talk about the importance
of Dewey if you would.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
Whew, where to start?
>> Stephen Winick: Because I
didn't know that you'd been
so influenced by
Dewey personally
which is [multiple speakers].
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: Well,
when I went and knocked
on his door you know,
sent there by Roger Mason,
what happened was when I went to
knock on his door in [inaudible]
at his house, a lot of people
had come by that point,
you know Roger Mason and Ron
and Fay Stanford and a few.
There was a lot of people
who had come in, musicians
and folklorists and other folks
but not anybody from home yet.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: And so,
you know he said,
where are you from?
I said I'm from near Lafayette.
He told me, you're
not going away.
He thought you're
You're going to be here.
I could ride this
horse for a long time.
And he was always very open
to, you know, people coming
in from the outside,
Tracy Schwartz
and all these people came in
from the outside but I think he,
leading up to the first
concert in 1974 he began
to make important
contacts with local folks.
And I'm not just talking about
Robert Jordell [phonetic]
who was, you know just
interested in playing music
with him, which was already
a big deal, but I'm talking
about what Dewey often called
the people who determine things,
you know the movers and shakers,
the people who could make
inroads in the university
or festival programming
or television programming.
Or, you know he was keenly
aware that there are some people
who have access to those things
and if he could, you know,
jig them in [laughter].
>> Nancy Groce: Was he that
way throughout this life?
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: Oh yeah.
>> Nancy Groce: And
or affected his life?
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: Well
I mean, when I met him.
I don't know how far back it
went but when, you see he was,
he was recorded by
Rinzler in '64.
But, by then he had already been
playing with his own family band
and also Nathan Abshire
and a few other people.
So, he had a public
performance persona
but in '64 something
remarkably different happened.
He became introspective, aware
of what was going on in a way
that I don't know any, no
other musician was aware
of it that way.
And it had a lot to do with what
he and Rinzler talked about.
Ralph saw in Dewey a, you
know a willing participant
in this conversation and
well Dewey was the first,
one of the first Cajun musicians
that anybody ever heard
explaining a song or explaining
where the band was or
explaining what they were doing.
And his own brother,
Will [assumed spelling] would
often say when they came
to play the festival oh 'Dewey
will parle' Dewey is going
to talk, that's what he does.
But he had learned to do that,
you know and Will didn't do it.
Nathan didn't do it.
None of those other
people did it.
Dewey did that.
So he was already sort of aware,
kind of plugged into the notion
that something remarkably
different was happening,
was available to happen
and that drew young people
like Michael Doucet and me, Nick
Spitzer, a lot of other people
to him because he got it.
You know he was very
intelligent, not,
he didn't have a
lot of education
but he was extremely
intelligent.
I mean he saw what the issue
was, oh there, that's the nerve.
There's the nerve, I see it.
>> Stephen Winick: What
was his teaching like?
I mean, how was it, to be
sitting there with him and?
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: Well,
teaching about what's going on
or what kind of strategy you
might need to be developed for,
I don't know, presenting
a festival or something
like that, was conversational.
Anybody who learned
music from him,
it was much more,
you know regimental.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: I mean
he said, you know he used
to use the metaphor, the corner
post, where the basic fingering
for the fiddle, this
is where you start.
Everything goes back to this.
Every, start here and
come back to here,
this is the corner post.
So, the way that he learned
music, I mean the way
that he taught music to
people like David Greely
and Steve Riley [inaudible]
he said look,
play it this way exact, and
David Greely is the same way.
David Greely learned from
him and he's the same way.
He said no, I didn't say
do this, I said to this.
You're doing this.
I want you to do
this [laughter].
He also had a very, at the same
time, a very flexible notion
of what was being done.
I mean you know if you
sang, I don't know,
say if you sang words to a song
that weren't the way he
would have sung it he didn't.
I never saw him have
a problem with that.
>> Nancy Groce: Who
was his mentor?
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: He
learned from his family.
He learned from people that
he was playing with you know,
Austin Pete and some
of the people
that were playing, Nathan.
But, I don't know that he had
what one would call a mentor.
>> Nancy Groce: One, yeah.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: No,
I think he made this up.
He intuited it.
>> Nancy Groce: And how old
was he when you met him?
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
Oh, I don't know,
a lot younger than I am now.
He wasn't an old man.
I guess he was in
maybe his late 40s.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: Or so.
>> Stephen Winick: And it's also
interesting how probably part
of his transformation into such
a force in Cajun culture came
from interacting a
little bit with outsiders.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
Oh absolutely.
>> Stephen Winick: You know,
and Ralph being part of it.
So explain how his, you know
his connection to Ralph Rinzler
and to Newport and all that may
have helped in this process?
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: You know
it's interesting to remember
that Dewey went to that first
Newport Festival in 1964
as a last-minute
replacement on guitar.
And he ended up playing
the guitar so much.
He wasn't used to playing
guitar and he ended
up playing the guitar so
much his fingertips were numb
and bleeding.
But you have to wonder
what might have happened.
I guess eventually it would have
happened anyway but you have
to wonder what might have
happened if you know,
the guy who was supposed to
go on guitar had gone and you,
if he had been willing
to get on the plane,
what would have happened
with Dewey?
I think Dewey had
already been recorded.
He had already met Ralph and
I think he had already had
that epiphany, you know it's
like, oh, something is up here,
something potentially
interesting and powerful is up.
But when he got to Newport
I mean he saw what happened
and you know, he was a
terribly quick study.
He got it.
Oh, I get what's happening.
I get this.
I see what's happening.
Because already, that first
year at Newport he noticed,
you know the Tommy
Garrells [phonetic]
and the Monroe Brothers
[assumed spelling]
and you know all
the other people
who were there, performers.
Oh, I see what does that.
I see what makes that crowd
[inaudible] a little faster,
a little fancier, you
know perform a little bit,
you know public performance,
public persona.
He figured it out right away
and he also heard them
talking to the crowd.
He heard the presenters doing it
but then he heard them doing
it too and thought oh, okay.
I could see where
that would be useful.
They don't know who I am.
They don't know what this
is, just help them understand
who we are, why we're
doing this.
I mean within the first year
he was already doing that.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah,
and it's like he came back
as a combination of a
musician and a presenter.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
Yeah, absolutely.
He came back, the way he put it
himself was, he said I wanted
to bring home the echo of
that ovation, of that applause
that we heard in Newport.
I wanted to get people from
south Louisiana to hear
that our music was appreciated.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah,
what did that mean to someone
in south Louisiana at that time?
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: Oh, I
mean in the, in the early 1960s
when that happened you know,
Cajun music was appreciated
by a segment of the
population but by other segments
of the population was considered
old and passee and raucous.
I mean look in 1965 a guy
named Burton Grindstaff
who did a column for the
Opelousas Daily World Newspaper
heard that they were, what
he called talent scouts
from Newport in the area
looking to bring musicians,
to take musicians
up there with them.
And he said, he wrote
in a column what an
embarrassment this would be.
I mean he said there's.
He said there's music,
there's Cajun music
and then there's you know, music
and they don't want anything
to do with each other.
He said it's like cats
fighting under the porch.
And he said.
He made a prediction.
He said it would be terrible
and embarrassing if one
of those talent scouts took
some of these recordings
that they're making
back up there
and they got a faulty
needle and heard it wrong
and thought it was good
and invited us up there.
What an embarrassment
it would be.
Well it turns out it wasn't
an embarrassment at all,
it was exactly the opposite.
So you know, there was a
prevailing notion among certain
segments of the society that
this was, well they referred
to it as nothing but
shankey shank [phonetic].
It was considered old
and passee and you know
with the Americanization process
it was precisely something
that Cajuns should be
trying to get away from,
run [inaudible] away from.
And Dewey said, well no,
they're loving this up there.
Why wouldn't we love it?
Why can't we appreciate
our own treasure?
When he started talking to
Jimmy Domengeaux, the chairman
of the council for the
development of French
in Louisiana about Cajun music,
it happened before '74,
a few years before.
CODOFIL was created to restore
French in Louisiana, to preserve
and restore French in Louisiana.
And Dewey understood,
or thought,
understood that you
know, you don't.
Language and culture
are not separable.
I mean language doesn't
exist in a vacuum,
it exists to express
things in a culture.
And so he started trying
to talk to Jimmy Domengeaux
about integrating, incorporating
local Louisiana French cultural
effects into this
effort to try to preserve
and promote the French
language of Louisiana
and Domengeaux was
not a Cajun music fan.
He was more like the
Burton Grindstaff, you know.
He liked jazz, he liked
New Orleans Dixieland jazz.
And he thought that, the only
Cajun music he had ever heard
was, you know raucous and
kind of out of tune and played
by a bunch of drunks or I
don't know what, something.
And Dewey was talking to him.
He talked to him over a
number occasions and he said,
you know, you don't like this.
You think you don't like this
because you've only
heard it poorly played.
If you heard it well played
you would change your mind.
And Domengeaux of course
would blow him off.
Oh, I don't know about all that.
You Balfa boys want to try to
bring this, that raucous stuff.
Well, at one point Dewey
Balfa and Leo LeBlanc
who was the representative
of the Quebec government
in Lafayette helping CODOFIL to
conceptualize what it was doing.
Leo LeBlanc was a guitar player
from New Brunswick originally
and he understood
Dewey's message and he
and Dewey blindsided Domengeaux
at a party just outside
of Lafayette, between
Lafayette and [inaudible].
They were at somebody's
camp and he said,
oh that's one of the Balfas.
That's one of those Balfas
that's always talking
about that damn Cajun music.
And he said I got my fiddle in
the car and Leo has a guitar,
let me play you something
and Dewey played of course.
Dewey was you know great
right, Dewey plays his stuff.
And Domengeaux says wow, I
never anything like that.
And that was the
beginning of the flip.
A few, just a short time
later Domengeaux accepted the,
you know, the idea to
produce that first concert.
By the way, did you ever
hear about how that happened?
>> Stephen Winick: Tell us.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
It started out to
be a demonstration
to 150 French-language
journalists from all
over the world who happened
to be having their convention
in Lafayette and CODOFIL,
Domengeaux was concerned
that they.
He wanted them to write positive
things about the presence
of the French language
in Louisiana.
He didn't want them to
write about, you know,
this whole thing is dead.
And so he was trying to figure
out ways to present them some,
some local culture in French.
And up until then CODOFIL
had been very cerebral.
It had been top-down.
It had been, you know,
imported French from France.
And Dewey kept saying you know
we have this stuff from here.
We could show them.
And after he heard that
performance, that improvised,
impromptu performance
at the camp,
he said well maybe
so, maybe so you know.
So we started talking
to him and I had worked
on the Smithsonian
Festival in '74 so I kind
of had a notion of,
I had met Ralph
and we started working
on this thing.
And CODOFIL representatives
and Domengeaux accepted
to do this concert but it
was supposed to be a very,
very slow-key, small
format thing.
>> Nancy Groce: And where
was it taking place?
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: Well,
it was going to take place
in a theater on campus, look
it, you know, seating capacity
of about 350 or 400 people.
It was mostly, it was
for the journalists.
It was just going to be a
demonstration of Cajun music
to them and Creole music.
Then we started.
As we were working on
this we thought, you know,
maybe some people from
the public might want to,
might be interested in coming
so we decided to open it
up a little bit to a
nearby ballroom and then
to a larger venue in
the municipal auditorium
which seated about 3000.
Because we were getting
feedback from the public, yeah,
you know I might want to like.
I might want to see that.
And then we ended up with
the Blackham Coliseum
which had a capacity
of 12,000 people.
But Domengeaux at that point
got cold feet and he said man,
you know if we do this in
there and it's half full,
it's going to look half empty.
There's going to be
a lot of empty seats.
I don't know why but I felt
like you know this
[inaudible] is going to work.
I think it's going to work.
I was all-in.
You know on the poker
table, I was all-in.
And we ended up doing it
there and Leo LeBlanc,
that same Leo LeBlanc was
writing press releases,
sending them out in the
newspaper, getting people kind
of excited about this.
But honestly, we had no idea
if anybody was going to come.
We didn't.
I didn't even know if the
musicians were going to come.
We weren't paying them anything.
And we were talking
about Clifton Chenier
and the Balfa Brothers and
Nathan Abshire and [inaudible]
and Canray, I mean you know.
And we didn't know if any
of them would show up.
And then, that day,
it starts pouring
down raining, I mean
cats and dogs.
There was a foot
and a half of water
on Johnson [assumed
spelling] Street right outside
of the coliseum.
I thought, oh well there's it.
You know if this
goes bad I'm done.
I'm just moving to
California or something.
I'm going to be done here.
Well, about 4.
The schedule started at 7.
About 4:30 Lionel LeLieux,
"Bois Sec" Ardoin and Canray
and a couple of ballad singers
showed up, their pants rolled
up above their knees,
walking through.
Where do we plug in?
Well, this may work,
something is going to happen.
Sure enough, everybody
showed up.
The people start
coming, coming and coming
and coming and coming.
It's still raining
cats and dogs.
People are pouring in there.
It filled the place up.
I thought Oh My God,
this is way.
We had set up.
We had set up, can you see this?
If you think of this as an oval,
we had set up the stage here
so that even, if we just
got two-thirds of the crowd.
>> Stephen Winick:
Right, right, right.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
It wouldn't look so bad.
They filled backstage too.
It filled everywhere.
The whole place was surrounded.
Look at this and it went off.
It was an amazing night.
The energy, people were hearing
this music for the first time
that way and you could
tell there was a buzz.
People were talking.
And so I went to
Domengeaux backstage
and I said you owe
me an apology.
And he said I don't
apologize to anybody
but he said but you were right.
This is amazing and
that's what started.
That's what plugged Dewey
Balfa into the local community
in a very serious way.
He became an icon for us.
That had already started
happening at Newport and Chicago
and other national
folk festivals
and those other places,
the Smithsonian but he.
>> Stephen Winick: He
was sort of an icon
of Cajun music to the outside.
Then he became, yeah.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: [Multiple
speakers] he really hit the
stride after that.
>> Nancy Groce: Can you explain?
When you were growing up,
were you aware of Cajun music?
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
Oh yeah, sure.
>> Nancy Groce: How
was Cajun music?
How was your family structured
or where did they
fall in the community?
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
My dad was a barber.
My mother was a beautician.
There was always a hair
in the soup in our family.
But you know, working
class folks and.
>> Nancy Groce: Was there
music in your family?
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
No, nobody played.
My father whistled
that was about it.
But, he was a great
whistler too man.
He couldn't carry a tune
vocally to save his soul
but he could whistle
like, amazing.
But, no, you know we
would hear Cajun music,
go to a wedding dance
or sometimes we'd go
out to a party somewhere
and somebody was playing.
We had some records.
Daddy's favorite record was
the Ira LeJeune reissues.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
And we heard Aldus Roger
and the Lafayette Playboys
on Saturday afternoons
on television.
And you know it's just
something that was always there.
We weren't all that, I mean
to be honest, you know,
we had the Beatles and Bob Dylan
and the Rolling Stones and all
that other stuff going,
Chuck Berry and all
that stuff going on, right,
so that was really the
bulk of our musical world.
But there was this stuff and it
was ours and I enjoyed listening
to that as much as
anything else.
I didn't do it as often until I
realized, oh wait, this is us.
This is what we have.
This is the treasure
that we need to value.
>> Stephen Winick: And
your, your early training
and you mentioned that you went
to Indiana originally
to study French?
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: I did.
>> Stephen Winick:
French literature
as opposed to folklore.
So, that was the angle that
you first came to it from.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: Yeah,
I've got to tell you, you know,
for me studying French
after that 8th grade class,
studying French was really
the path of least resistance.
It was lazy.
It was the lazy way.
[Inaudible] was easy for me,
I spoke French from home.
I walked into a classroom and
I already knew it was a plume
and papier and [foreign
language spoken].
I knew all that stuff.
I knew how to, nobody had
to teach me how to make it,
do the 'passe compose'.
I knew how to say 'I ate
something yesterday'.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
So, what I had to figure
out was two things,
one, how to write
and read what I already
knew how to say but also how
to negotiate a place
for the local vernacular
into the larger scheme
of the way the French
language works in the world.
That ended up becoming one
of my 'cheval de
guerre' over my career.
I did not want to I didn't want
to declare independence
for Cajun French.
I wanted to force the French
to accept us at the table.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah, I
mean that, it makes sense
as a strategy in the sense
that French is a huge force
in the world and why
separate yourself
from that if you could join it.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: Yeah,
and early, early on in that,
the going was pretty
tough because you know,
the French can be very, kind
of closed-minded
about what French is.
>> Stephen Winick: Sure.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: You
know [foreign language spoken]
as they say.
And it was with the eventual
explosion on to the concept
of La Francophonie where
you know, there were lots
of countries in the world
where French was spoken
but not necessarily like France
and their references
were not French.
They were West African or
Northern African or Belgian
or Quebecois or Louisianan.
And once that notion of a
larger context for French
in the Francophone world emerged
it enabled places like Louisiana
to figure out a way to
preserve our own specificity,
the way which, because
you know, the business
about preserving French and
teaching French in Louisiana,
what's the point unless it's the
French that produced those songs
and stories that we value
so much, I mean right?
That was not an easy
goal in the beginning.
I mean I remember people from
France would come to visit us,
to visit this sort of you
know, linguistic museum
or something [laughter],
linguistic living museum
and they would say.
We would say something in
French and they would say,
oh [foreign language spoken],
you know, that's not said.
And we'll finally learn to
say [foreign language spoken].
Of course it's said,
I just said it.
And then they would say oh.
They figured out well, you know,
it may not be politically
correct to, you know judge
like that so they started saying
oh [foreign language spoken]
it's interesting
how you say that.
Then we learned to say no,
here it's not interesting
at all, here it's usual.
Here, you're interesting and
like it turned the tables
on them [laughter]
especially people from France.
But, two things, two
people I usually,
I offer to quote in that regard.
One, ironically is Nicolas
Sarkozy, the former president
of France who said,
referring to la Francophonie
that its biggest weakness
was that it was the only one
who didn't recognize its own
strength, if you understand.
>> Stephen Winick:
The only one of what?
I'm sorry.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: The
only [foreign language spoken].
>> Stephen Winick: I
see, okay yeah, right.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
La Francophonie doesn't
recognize its own strength.
>> Stephen Winick:
Everybody else recognizes it
but La Francophonie
does not, right, yeah.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
Yeah, right, right,
and what he meant was it's
actually a sign of strength,
this diversity, this
linguistic diversity.
It's not a sign of
French being deteriorated.
On the contrary, it's a sign
of French being enriched
by all these variant contexts.
And the other is a novelist, a
Quebecois novelist who wrote the
"The couteau sur la
table" Jacques Godbout,
who wrote in the preface of that
novel [foreign language spoken].
Instead of being French we
prefer to be ourselves in French
and therein is precisely
what, you know,
what I think we were
after in Louisiana.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah, that's
a great quote [laughter].
So, you know being at.
Yeah, go on.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
Interestingly,
no interestingly you
know I didn't talk a lot
about the French side of it, I
talked about the folklore side
of it but the two were in
my mind, in my experience,
the two were inextricably
linked.
It was all part of
the same thing
and that same thing was finding
and recognizing and valuing
that ourselves, who we are and
how we speak and what we do,
how we sing, how we
dance, everything.
It was all part of
the same thing
and the French language
was a part of that.
In fact I sometimes got
accused of being so attached
to the French expression
of things that I was kind
of turning up my nose at some
of the groups in South Louisiana
who were singing in English.
And I said guilty as charged.
I mean it is a French thing.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
You know, for me,
I mean I'm not saying other
people should not do that
but for me that was what
I was interested in.
>> Stephen Winick:
Yeah, well I mean one
of the things that's
interesting is
that when folklorists
approach something
like a French diaspora one
of the tendencies is for them
to try to trace stuff back to
France just because of the,
sort of valuing things
that are very old.
If you look at Dewey's early
recordings a lot of the songs
that he did, did have
connections to France
and I wonder if that was
organic to his repertoire
or if it was part
of his recognizing
that that's would play well with
CODOFIL and other organizations
that were interested in him.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
Well, I'm not sure
that the second was his motive.
The first was one
of his motives.
But the other thing, you know,
he was, he was interested
in what was profoundly
us about those songs.
And a lot of 'us'
was really old stuff.
He enlisted the help of his
brothers and other people,
his sisters, his aunts I mean to
mine the family tradition for,
you know, the oldest
songs they could remember,
sometimes [inaudible] songs
like [foreign language spoken].
And so he was trying to
reach as far back as he could
but he was also valuing
contemporary creation,
as long as it seemed
like it was in a flow.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: You
know a recognizable flow.
But what you said
about you know,
sometimes people get stuff
going back to France, we did.
We did and it was sort of
like a self-defence mechanism.
You know, the French keep
saying that you know,
some of the stuff we
say, is an erosion,
it represents an
erosion of the language.
But we started looking
into it and it turns
out they weren't erosions at
all, they were preservations
of the ways things had been,
except that you had to go
to the exact provinces, you
know [foreign language spoken],
you know those areas where the
original settlers had come from.
If you go there they still
refer to a coffee pot
as not [foreign language spoken]
but [foreign language
spoken] like we do.
So, and they still, you know
conjugate the imparfait [foreign
language spoken] instead
of [foreign language
spoken] so it wasn't.
We weren't making mistakes
we were preserving the way,
some of the things that we had
inherited from our origins.
And sometimes those were songs.
Now one of the reasons why
the Lomax Collection was
so profound, it was a watershed
moment when we heard that.
And the reason, one of
the reasons was that up
until then our notion of the
way Cajun music had evolved was
based on the commercial
recordings.
Those were as far back in
history as we could go.
And we had been all
profoundly influenced
by Chris Strachwitz's historical
re-releases, you know going back
to the late 20s and 30s and 40s
and he was sort of putting it
into a sort of historical sweep.
And it made sense right?
You know, there was
this early stuff
and then there was the
swing band influence stuff.
And then there was the war stuff
and the post-war stuff and so
that made sense and it was
telling a very compelling story.
Then the Lomax Collection,
it was like whoa.
It was, a lot of the
stuff was way older.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
It was recorded in '34
but the Lomaxes were looking for
people who were representative
of pre-commercial
recording stuff.
All of a sudden you
start thinking oh wait,
man all these ballads, all
of this lyrical treasure
of lyrics that come from way.
A lot of this stuff you could
actually connect through Quebec
and Acadie, all the
way back to France.
I mean whew, we had to
rethink the whole thing
and sometimes one of
things that occurred to me
as I was listening to this stuff
was hey, I recognize that theme.
I recognize that
[foreign language spoken].
But in the ballads it
was elaborated with four
or five verses where
it, you know intricate,
whereas in the dance music
lyrics it had gotten compressed.
It got tight and compressed
and impressionistic.
But that's obviously
where it had come from.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
Yeah, so you have the new
compositions actually coming
out of these older traditions
but you hadn't realized it.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: [Multiple
speakers] or people who were at,
at least sort of
conceptually aware of them.
They weren't word for word
but they were addressing
the same themes you know.
>> Nancy Groce: In your
talk you were very eloquent
about new creations
coming in just
as you're saying now is
kind of a, part of a tide
that keeps going, a
river that keeps going.
Could you talk a little bit
about your contributions
to that?
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
Mine, in what way?
>> Stephen Winick: Well, I mean,
well talk about Jean Arsenault.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
[Laughter] well,
you know if you hang out with
those guys long enough you know
you kind of say I'm
interested in doing that.
I could do that.
>> Nancy Groce: You mean
in actually writing just
for these [multiple speakers]?
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: Yeah,
yeah so the first time I did
that was for Wayne Toups.
He called me one night and said
I've got this song I want to do
but the lyrics are
in [inaudible].
I wrote the, you know the lyrics
are written down in English
but you know, my notion
of it is in French.
Could you come and help me?
So I went and we and I
developed the lyrics for
"Un Amour Secret"
was the first song.
And when I heard that, I had
a moment not unlike Dewey's
at Newport.
You know I was in the
studio watching that happen.
The next thing you know
this whole band is playing
and he's singing lyrics that I
just came up with and I thought,
I love this, it's
really great [laughter].
Man this is really cool, so.
>> Nancy Croce: You did
it as a pseudonym though?
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: Yeah.
>> Nancy Groce: Yeah and why,
please talk a little
bit about that.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: And the
pseudonym is older than that.
You want to hear this?
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah, sure.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
Jean Arsenault was born
when Barry Ancelet was 27
years old in Quebec City.
I was in. I was in Quebec
for [foreign language
spoken] Francophone,
a large international gathering
of Francophone people hosted
by the Quebec government.
Quebec used to do this a lot
because I think they wanted
to sort of reassure themselves
that they weren't alone in this,
and so they would bring in
Acadians and Louisianans
and sometimes people
from Missouri,
other French-speaking, Ontario.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah, they
wanted to be sort of the capital
of French America
in a way, yeah.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: Yeah
and they wanted to kind
of signal we're not alone
in this effort you know.
So, there was this [inaudible]
in 1978 and I was there
as a. I was there to give
a talk on the integration
of Louisiana French style of
speaking into the classroom.
And when I got there we
learned that there had been,
there was a literary
event, a poetry reading.
It was called [foreign
language spoken].
It was to be poetry
readings and music.
The part of the music part, the
part of the music side of it
that they were going to present
was a, the symphony orchestra
of the City of Quebec was
going to debut a symphony piece
that Claude Levier [phonetic]
had written composed in honor
of Helene, Samuel
de Champlain's wife.
So there was a symphony
orchestra onstage
and there were these poets.
Quebec had a long
history, Gaston Miron
and Michel Alon [phonetic] and
all of these, a long history
of poetry used as
social fuel to,
you know protest being
drowned out, to protest,
like Michel Alon's
[inaudible] you know that kind.
So they were having
this literary event
and we learned upon arriving
there that they had forgotten
to integrate, to include
Louisiana and it was like a,
like a gaffe, you
know, what can we do?
Well, nobody in Louisiana
at that point, that I knew,
was writing poetry in French.
I mean there were people
who had written songs
and Zachary Richard,
my dear friend
from home had written some
new songs but I don't know
that anybody would have
thought of it as poetry.
It was but, so I'm talking to
the organiser of this thing,
Marcel Dube and he
says well you know,
this is a terrible you
know embarrassment.
We have to include Louisiana.
Well, it turns out that I had
written a few poems in reaction
to a woman that I had met
earlier that year in Moncton,
originally from Quebec but
she was living in Moncton.
I'd kind of been smitten by her
and I wrote a few
things about her.
And her name was Louise and
there was an opportunity to sort
of make a confluence of Louise
and Louisiana, as you know,
a potential mistress
that you're.
>> Nancy Groce: Muse, muse.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
You know your muse
that you're smitten by, so it
was like a. It was like being
in love in your place, so
there was a confluence.
So, I didn't want to
force his hand and I was.
After we finished this thing
in Quebec I was on my way back
over there to see
if that was going,
how that was going to play out.
So I had these things
I had written about her
but I hadn't intended to show
anybody but he's pressing me
so I said well, I
have this friend.
I didn't want to
press, force his hand.
I said I have a friend who
has written a few things and.
He said [inaudible].
I said I happen to have some
here and so I showed him.
And he said who is this?
I said his name is
Jean Arsenault.
My name is Barry Jean Ancelet
and my grandmother was
[inaudible] Arsenault so I was.
I mean right there
as fast as that.
He reads the stuff.
He says oh, this is
perfect, perfect.
You'll read this.
Call him and ask
him for permission.
So, he hands me a phone.
This is 1978.
This is before cell phones or
answering machines or anything.
So I called the number
at my apartment
in Lafayette knowing
nobody was there.
>> Stephen Winick: Right, right.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
And I had a conversation
with Jean Arsenault as the
phone was ringing in my ear,
to get his permission
because now then, I was caught
in my lie, to get his
permission to do this.
So, I hung up and I
said he said it's okay.
So he said well you'll
read this.
And then I thought wait
Zachary Richard is here.
He's here to perform
in a concert.
He had a bit hit so I
went over to where his,
where the concert
setting was going to be
and the [foreign
language spoken]
and Zachary Richard already by
then was a big thing in Quebec.
It would be like going to
some, you know, big festival
in England and say
hey, I need to talk
to Mick Jagger, like
yeah, right.
>> Stephen Winick:
I'm his friend
from home [laughter] right.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
I was like yeah like,
so I told the guard there.
I said [foreign language
spoken] and he said you
and about 500 other people.
I said no, no, no I really.
No, he said yeah, the
same 500 other people.
But while we're talking over
his shoulder I see Ralph,
Zackary Richard come out of
his [foreign language spoken]
trailer and I knew because you
know he went by Zachary Richard
but we all called him Ralph.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
From back home,
so I knew the only way I could
get his attention was I yelled
'hey Ralph'.
He turned around and he said,
oh, what are you doing here?
And he told the security,
let him in.
And the security guard
[inaudible] let me in.
And I said look,
here's the deal.
They want us to participate in
this literary thing, evening.
And I got one thing but
I need something else.
Do you have any songs that
you haven't yet recorded
that we could claim as poetry?
He said yeah, I have
a few things.
So we picked Le Ballade de
[foreign language spoken]
and those are the two things
that I read that night.
And there were about 3000
people in the courtyard
of the [foreign language
spoken] in Quebec.
I'd never experienced
anything like that in my life.
I couldn't have dreamed it.
And I got a standing
ovation I guess in large part
because people were
so astonished
that this existed
in Louisiana at all.
But I was really, I had a
moment like [inaudible] oh man,
so when I got back home and I
called Ralph, Zachary Richard.
I said man you're not going
to believe what happened.
I read these things and
he said yeah, I know,
this happens to me all the time.
I said no, but you're
singing, it's different.
When you're singing
it's different.
I was just speaking these words
and it electrified the
whole place and me too.
He said okay.
I said we have to do this here.
It was the same principle.
We have to do this here.
So we organized a series
of [foreign language
spoken] music in Lafayette.
And I had had so much fun
with Jean Arsenault I
elected to keep him around.
And so all of the literary
things that I wrote
and published on some
lyrics, stories, whatever,
I published under the
pseudonym of Jean Arsenault.
>> Stephen Winick: And how
many collections did you,
did you publish or under
that name [inaudible]?
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
Oh, six or seven
and a lot of song lyrics.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: All
of the song lyrics I did
for Wayne Toups and Richard
LeBouef and Steve Riley
and even D.L. Menard
and a few other people,
they were all done
under Jean Arsenault.
And Floyd Soileau
with Swallow Records
in Louisiana said you need to
tell people who you are man.
I said no man, this is so
much fun, I'm having a blast.
Because Jean Arsenault, when
Jean Arsenault would show
up for a poetry reading
or a performance he could
look really different.
>> Stephen Winick: [Laughter]
no one can tell it's you?
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: I often,
I would often wear
a Mardi Gras mask.
>> Nancy Groce: Did
your colleagues
at the university know
you were [inaudible]?
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
Yeah, yeah,
I mean it was this,
in a way it was.
After a while it was
the worst-kept secret
in French Louisiana but
never the less it was fun
because it was kind of
like having a stage persona
that was able to play out
there where there was no stage.
It would be used in real life.
You know Jean Arsenault
could show up in.
And the other thing
about Jean Arsenault was
that Jean Arsenault never
had to worry about English.
He never had to deal
with English.
He was exclusively
French-speaking, right.
One time when I was doing
the KRVS Morning Show
that Pete Bergeron
does now from 6
to 7:30 I did an interview
with Jean Arsenault.
I would just.
I would just ask a
question and then answer it.
And you know I didn't
even change my voice.
I just asked a question
and then answered it.
And some people started
calling the studio and said hey,
I want to talk to that guy.
He wrote the lyrics
to a Wayne Toups.
He said I want to talk to
you to see if he could.
I said well hold
on a second, hello?
>> Stephen Winick: And no
one, no one could tell?
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: It
was so much fun you know.
>> Stephine Winick:
That's fun, that's great.
>> Nancy Groce: And you
started performing as him also?
Are you singing now?
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: Well,
Sam Brousard convinced me
to use my real name on that CD.
>> Nancy Groce: Yeah, talk
a little bit about the CD.
The title of the CD was?
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
"Broken Promised Land".
>> Nancy Groce: And
when did that come out?
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: Which
was based on The Promised Land
where Ben [inaudible] was
[inaudible] tell the stories.
>> Nancy Groce: And
when did that come out?
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: A couple
of years ago and what is 2016.
And I didn't even know
we were making a CD.
I thought we were just
goofing around in Sam's studio.
He had a studio at home.
>> Stephen Winick: Right.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: I had
written a bunch of lyrics.
He started putting them to
music and at one point he said,
hey I want you to
sing on some of these.
Like really?
>> Nancy Groce: Had
you sung before?
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
Happy Birthday and,
no I used to sing a
little bit at The Liberty,
you know I would sing
every once in a while.
I sang with The Wandering
Aces, Lionel LeLieux
and Don Montoucet
for a little while.
I used to have a little bit of a
voice, I don't have one anymore.
I told that to Sam, I said all
I've got is this gravely thing
and he said that's
all you need for this
because it's our bluesy stuff.
Anyway we recorded, but I
thought we were just playing
and after about ten
songs he says, you know,
what are we going
to do with this?
What are we going
to do with what?
He said well, we've
got ten songs.
Really, okay, what could we?
He said we could put out a CD.
I said how would we do that?
Well, he said we
could do it ourselves.
I said uh uh, I don't want
to be in the CD business.
He said, well let's pitch
it to somebody and see
if they will put it out?
And, so we talked
to Joe Alsalvor [phonetic]
first, about it.
He said he was too busy.
So I went over to Phil Blatt
[phonetic] and talked to Floyd
and Chris Soileau about it.
I've got to tell you.
I went in there with all
ten songs and he said.
I said Floyd, Floyd and
I have known each other
for a long time.
I said Floyd, I've got to
tell you before you hear this,
I said it's different,
like real different.
He said it's okay.
I could do different.
Okay, so he starts
listening to it
and listen you all, I'm serious.
I'm not making this up.
They listened to all ten songs
in a row with not a word.
I was like, oh man, this
is a train wreck, whoa.
And at the end of the,
in the tenth song
pushes the pause button
and he says well Ancelet,
when you said it was
different you weren't kidding.
But he said I'll tell you
what we're going to put this
out because I don't
want to be the joker
that didn't put this out.
So he puts this out on Swallow
Records, sort of routinely.
You know they send most
of the stuff that they put
out in a year for
consideration for the Grammys.
The damn thing gets nominated.
I thought.
I got that call one morning.
I was still in bed.
This voice said you know your CD
has been nominated for a Grammy.
I said, what are you saying?
What are you saying?
And they said yeah, no kidding,
in the Regional Roots category.
I thought oh man.
>> Stephen Winick: And if
I'm not mistaken it was
up against one of Joelle's
[phonetic] projects.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: Yeah and
I participated on that one too
so I was double-nominated
that year.
>> Stephen Winick:
But I bet he was sorry
that he hadn't said yes
to you at that point.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
[Laughter] he might have been.
Yeah, we were competing with,
Eddie and Roddy Ramirez'
[phonetic] album was also.
We were three from Louisiana.
We diluted our own
vote but that's okay.
You know I felt like being
nominated, I won anyway.
They gave me a medal
and everything.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah,
that's a great [inaudible]
just a great acknowledgement
for what you've done
over the years
and for the culture in general.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: Okay but
it was more of a surprise to me.
>> Stephen Winick:
Yeah [laughter].
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: I think
nobody was more surprised
than me.
Sam was not surprised.
He thought he had.
He thought, you know, this
is, you know different
and an important step.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
Interestingly I've got to say
over the last four, five,
six years I have seen the
[inaudible] steadily rising
on new production [foreign
language spoken] The Lost
Bayou Ramblers.
I mean it's amazing what's
happening, what's coming
out of South Louisiana
right now.
And one of the amazing
things is the quality of it,
the cleverness of it, you
know but another thing is
that it's still in French.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: It's
still coming out in French like,
I'm happy about that but I'm
you know kind of surprised.
>> Stephen Winick: One of
the things that we love
about it here at the library
and I know you've talked
about this a lot and will
continue to talk about it,
is the fact that those groups
are still using our archival
resources as their inspiration.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
Absolutely.
>> Stephen Winick: That
is they're recording just
like Michael Doucet was doing
25 years ago or 30 years ago
and Steve Riley was doing
20 years and 15 years ago.
They're doing it now and
recording versions of our songs.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
You know why,
you know why Michael
Doucet was the first?
Because he got, he got
the jump on the project
because when I brought back
the Lomax copies to home,
to the university, he
and I were sitting side
by side listening to the tape.
There were 11 reels.
We put on the first
one, started listening.
It was Wilfred Charles,
a jure singer but he was
by himself from New Iberia.
He got through that song and
he was singing about the Zydeco
in 1934 but whoa, whoa, whoa.
I pushed the pause button
and I turned to Michael
and I said man, we're
going to have
to rethink everything
we thought we knew.
The whole, it's a game-changer.
>> Nancy Groce: Because
it was so much earlier
than [multiple speakers]?
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: It
was represented so much
at an earlier tradition.
That first song that guy
was singing about Zydeco
and everybody said
Zydeco emerged in the 50s.
Well what was he doing
singing about in '34?
And he wasn't the only one,
there were two other songs.
>> Stephen Winick: Right, there
were some other ones yeah, yeah.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: And
then we started hearing all
that Hoffpower stuff and you
know the stuff that's coming
out of New Iberia and the
stuff coming out of Crowley.
It's like whoa the
lyrical richness
that we were hearing
was stunning.
So what do I do?
I start thinking okay,
how do we keep this going?
Lomax had said, Alan and/or
John had said as a tagline,
on a number of those cuts,
you know we're recording this
for the Library of Congress
so that it will be available
to musicians in the
future about it to learn.
I said well let's see that.
Let's do that.
So I started calling people in.
I said hey, do you want to
hear something interesting?
Michael had started
doing it already
and people were asking him,
where did you get that?
Well, it's in a Lomax cut.
Really, where is that?
So they were coming
to the archives,
musicians [inaudible]
can I hear that?
And they were starting to
pick songs and recycle them,
my Old Playboys [inaudible],
I mean you name it, Ann Savoy
and James Dream [phonetic],
a number of people.
So the next thing you know
there's all this bubbling
of brand new/old songs.
>> Stephen Winick: Yeah.
>> Nancy Groce: Well, it's
great for you to bring it back
to the library today and
to give us an overview
of what you've been doing,
what's been going
on in the area.
We could go on for hours
but I think we need
to [multiple speakers].
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: But
I want to say by the way
that on the record, I
want to say on the record
that the Library of Congress,
the American Folklife Center has
been so generous and supportive
of all of this and enabled
so much of this to happen.
We appreciate what you
all have done for us.
>> Stephen Winick: Well, we
absolutely appreciate everything
that you've done for the music.
One last point that
I'll make is I've worked
with those Louisiana
collections and the cataloguing,
the additional cataloguing
that you guys have
done is actually better
than what was done here in the
30s and 40s so there are songs
that we can find out
about [laughter] that are
in our collections
that we can only find
out about through your work.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
Josh Caffrey,
Josh Caffrey did an
amazingly meticulous job.
>> Stephen Winick: Absolutely.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet: Of
identifying some of this stuff
and finding out information
about the backstories
a lot times.
I mean I had started that
ball kind of you know
in discovering a few things
and then Josh, you know,
took the hand off and
ran for a touchdown.
>> Stephen Winick: We keep his
book in the Reading Room as one
of our basic resources
when people come in to talk
about that material so, yeah, so
thank you so much for the talk.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
Oh, a pleasure.
>> Stephen Winick: And for
talking to us in this interview.
>> Nancy Groce: [Inaudible]
to Washington, yes.
It's been a lovely.
>> Barry Jean Ancelet:
I've enjoyed it, thank you.